puedo imaginar a los primeros seres
humanos e incluso a ancestros más
antiguos preguntarse a sí mismos por qué
estoy aquí cuál es la naturaleza de la
realidad porque todo está organizado de
la manera en que lo está y estas
interrogantes son las que queremos
responder en el campo de la física que
se puede considerar justo después de las
matemáticas como una de las ciencias más
puras tenemos matemáticas que es una
ciencia bastante pura y apoyándose en el
fundamento de las matemáticas tenemos a
la física y la física trata de usar
estas matemáticas en conjunto con
algunas ideas centrales para explicar
todos los fenómenos del universo los
físicos son los primeros en admitir que
apenas están comenzando a comprender la
naturaleza de la realidad la naturaleza
de todo lo que nos rodea y muchas veces
pensamos que la física sólo se limita a
cosas como fenómenos cosmológicos
cohetes al espacio cómo se mueven las
olas o cómo se construyen las
estructuras pero la física es el
fundamento para todas las demás ciencias
cuando pensamos en la química que al
final del día son interacciones entre
átomos esas interacciones están basadas
en la física por lo que la química se
fundamenta en la física incluso cuando
pensamos en nosotros mismos nuestros
cuerpos nuestras conciencias incluso
nuestros cerebros todo en realidad se
reduce a la química y a la física todo
se reduce a interacciones entre átomos
las propiedades mecánicas de nuestro
cuerpo por lo que incluso la biología se
fundamenta en la química que a su vez se
fundamenta en la física la cual es muy
dependiente de alguna de las matemáticas
que ustedes han estado aprendiendo
durante toda su vida y que continuarán
aprendiendo y estas preguntas
fundamentales de bueno porque estoy
aprendiendo estas matemáticas
bueno primero porque las matemáticas son
hermosas pero ustedes verán que digamos
que de la manera más pura describe la
estructura del universo y esto lo
veremos cada vez más conforme vayamos
aprendiendo física todos estos fenómenos
complejos que vemos a nuestro alrededor
ya sea una galaxia o las olas del océano
o incluso observando sistemas biológicos
veremos que una tremenda cantidad de
estos podemos comenzar a describirlos
usando algunas matemáticas bastante
elegantes sobre las cuales podemos
construir conceptos más complejos
matemáticas elegantes como la fuerza
igual a la masa por la aceleración y
hablaremos de la fuerza y la aceleración
como cantidades vectoriales hablaremos
de cosas como el desplazamiento que
también lo pongo como cantidad de
vectorial y pronto aprenderemos a qué se
refiere esto de cantidades escalares y
vectoriales el desplazamiento es igual a
la velocidad por el tiempo
aprenderemos cosas como que la
aceleración es el cambio en la velocidad
entre el cambio en el tiempo
y veremos como un puñado de ideas
sencillas como estas nos pueden ayudar a
explicar cómo lo veremos en vídeos
posteriores una enorme cantidad de
fenómenos más complejos y una cosa que a
mí siempre me ha encantado de la física
y que no siempre es apreciada ya que a
veces cuando uno comienza a aprender
física vemos estas fórmulas complicadas
y estos problemas complejos pero lo
importante es darnos cuenta de que todo
eso viene de estas ideas básicas algunas
de las cosas que acabo de mencionar e
ideas como la energía que veremos con
las leyes de newton y que veremos cuáles
son los diferentes tipos de fuerza y por
qué es que existen y en esencia todo
esto nos sirve para tratar de explicar
la complejidad del universo predecir qué
es lo que puede pasar con base en ideas
sencillas en ideas básicas y de esto se
trata la física y bueno la física ha
sido estudiada por la humanidad
hace muchísimo tiempo atrás y de hecho
no tenemos idea de quiénes fueron los
primeros físicos pero algunos de los
pensadores que encontraron los
fundamentos de la física son estos
caballeros que vemos aquí podemos decir
que son algunos de los pensadores más
prominentes en la física pero sin duda
esto para nada es una lista completa
primero queremos incluir a isaac newton
especialmente cuando comenzamos a
aprender física comenzamos a comprender
al mundo de la manera en que newton
comenzó a comprenderlo él se dio cuenta
de que las cosas no cae en el suelo
solamente porque si encontró que hay una
fuerza que ocasiona esto y quizá es la
misma fuerza que hace que yo permanezca
sentada en esta silla y quizá es también
una fuerza es la misma que hace que los
planetas estén en órbita alrededor del
sol o que la luna esté en órbita
alrededor de la tierra el desarrollo la
ley de gravedad
leyes de newton las cuales vamos a
estudiar conforme vayamos aprendiendo de
nuestra física básica y veremos que
incluso la mecánica clásica la física
que newton estableció puede explicar un
gran abanico de fenómenos con
sorprendente precisión pero conforme
entramos a inicios del siglo 21 los
físicos comienzan a tener ideas bastante
alocadas conforme empezamos a
adentrarnos a la escala de los súper
pequeños tenemos a max planck que nos da
la mecánica cuántica y después tenemos a
albert eisntein cuando comenzamos a ver
velocidades enormes la velocidad de la
luz que es un absoluto nada puede viajar
más rápido que la velocidad de la luz lo
cual es un concepto casi increíble
tenemos estas nociones de la relatividad
general y especial y comenzamos a darnos
cuenta de que el universo es en cierta
forma más extraño y más bizarro y más
fascinante de lo que alguna vez pudimos
imaginar
todo el trabajo para comprender la
física moderna de max planck y albert
eisntein está basada en muchas de las
ideas centrales que nos dio isaac newton
e incluso de personas que existieron
antes que isaac newton así que conforme
avancemos en el estudio de la física y
yo siempre quise ser física ya que
realmente todos nos preguntamos por qué
estamos aquí cuál es la naturaleza de la
realidad y por qué ocurren las cosas de
la forma en que lo hacen todas estas son
preguntas que la física intenta
responder y conforme avancemos en el
estudio de la física quiero dejarles
algunas citas de estos caballeros las
primeras dos son de isaac newton la
verdad se encuentra en la simplicidad y
no en la multiplicidad ni en la
confusión de las cosas y quiero hacer
énfasis en esto porque muchas veces
cuando estamos estudiando muchas gracias
nos encontramos simplemente memorizando
fórmulas y vocabulario pero si hacemos
esto nuestro estudio va a ser solo
superficial
comenzamos a darnos cuenta de dónde se
originan estas fórmulas pues veremos que
vienen de ideas más sencillas e
intuitivas y es entonces cuando nos
acercamos a la verdad y me encanta esta
otra cita de isaac newton no sé lo que
le podré parecer al mundo pero a mí me
parece como si hubiese sido un niño que
juega en la orilla del mar y se divierte
de tanto en tanto encontrando un
guijarro más pulido o una concha más
hermosa de lo común mientras que el
inmenso océano de la verdad se extiende
inexplorado frente a mí y a mí me
encanta pensar que aún cuando pensemos
que hemos descubierto muchísimo de la
realidad solamente hemos aprendido
apenas un pedacito de todo lo que es en
realidad del universo incluso un genio
como isaac newton se dio cuenta de esto
se imagina como un niño que está jugando
apenas en la orilla del mar aún cuando
existe un inmenso océano de
que aún no se puede ni comenzar a
comprender podemos imaginar a
civilizaciones extraterrestres que nos
llevan miles de millones de años de
avance tecnológico y científico cómo es
que ellos podrían percibir la realidad
podrían vernos a nosotros como si
fuéramos hormigas ya que apenas estamos
arañando la superficie del conocimiento
de cómo funciona el universo estás sites
de max planck cuando cambias tu forma de
ver las cosas las cosas que observas
cambian y esto me gusta porque es muy
profundo realmente sucede conforme vamos
aprendiendo más de física muchas de las
cosas que consideramos nuestra realidad
nuestra comprensión actual se basa en
estas fuerzas pero cuando empezamos a
ver de qué se tratan estas fuerzas o
estas cosas que nosotros percibimos como
sólidas cuando llegamos a nivel atómico
nos damos cuenta que la mayoría es
espacio vacío y es solamente la
interacción de las fuerzas lo que nos
hace percibir que algo es sólido y qué
y que es tangible de cierta manera pero
en realidad estas cosas que creemos
tangibles pues no son tan tangibles
después de todo al final del día todo el
mundo es simplemente un modelo mental
que tenemos en nuestras cabezas es una
ilusión que crea nuestra mente para que
podamos funcionar en él pero apenas
estamos comenzando a comprenderlo por
último pero no por eso menos importante
y bueno hay muchísimas citas
interesantes de estas personas pero en
especial de albert eisntein lo más bello
que podemos experimentar es el misterio
es la emoción fundamental que acuna a la
verdadera ciencia y al arte verdadero y
de verdad quiero que se lleven esto con
ustedes conforme estudian física va a
haber momentos en el que vamos a estar
construyendo de nuestra caja de
herramientas que es un vector que es un
escalar viendo algo de matemáticas
haciendo demostraciones de ciertas
fórmulas esas van a ser nuestras
herramientas pero lo que queremos hacer
es comprender el fenómeno fundamental
como
que en realidad funciona el universo y
cuando uno de verdad comienza a
reflexionar en esto la piel se nos pone
de gallina y sentimos que el universo es
más misterioso de lo que nos hubiéramos
imaginado de no ser así estamos
estudiando física de la manera
incorrecta